ou Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen ont
fait leur meilleur et leur pire score au
second tour de la présidentielle on
regarde ça tout de suite pour les villes
Emmanuel Macron a fait plus de 80% des
voix à Nantes Rennes Bordeaux et Paris
Marine Le Pen a elle fait plus de 60% à
Calais Marignane ou Hénin-Beaumont en
tout la candidate du rassemblement
national est arrivé en tête dans 18156
communes contre 16 922 pour Emmanuel
Macron niveau département c'est à Paris
qu'Emmanuel Macron a fait son plus gros
score avec 85,1% des voix il est même
monté à 90% dans le troisième
arrondissement le président réélu a
aussi fait un carton en Bretagne avec
notamment 70,9% des voix en
Ille-et-Vilaine Marine Le Pen fait son
meilleur score dans les outre-mer avec
69,6% des voix en Guadeloupe et plus de
60% en Martinique et en Guyane des
chiffres qui se sont totalement inversés
en 5 ans puisqu'en 2017 Emmanuel Macron
avait récolté plus de 60% des voix dans
ces trois départements enfin dans le
village d'Asie en Corse les deux
candidats ont fait zéro voie un seul des
34 réacteurs inscrits s'est déplacé mais
son bulletin était nul